you know what I love I love one when I'm
in a public place and I do something
amazing and somebody sees it give it you
have like a random moment of greatness
and there's witnesses it doesn't even
have to be anything big like you ever
like knock your hat off your head and
you like catch it behind your back
somebody sees it my god
what a rush I was at an airport and I
was going through security and they
wouldn't let me take my water through
very dangerous and so I chugged my water
and then I was looking around for the
nearest recycle bin I found it was like
15 feet away I was like I'm going for it
and so I started aim and there's no
water left in this you know required a
lot of precision very like and then the
actual bin just had a tiny little circle
just big enough for a can or a bottle to
go into a high degree of difficulty but
I'm like I'm doing this I'm going for I
throw it perfect rotation right in the
hole just disappeared and I mean they
were like everybody in line saw the
whole thing go down and yeah I don't I
don't want to make up a story and say
they all started clapping or something
but they wanted to I saw a couple people
we can bring their hand jab and they're
like okay we're in an airport let's
relax what a rash
that was eight years ago I still think
about it every day those random moments
of greatness it's got to be random
though it's got to be an accident you
can't tell people you're about to do
something amazing you know these people
who are like hey watch this watch this
whenever somebody says hey watch this
I'm like I hope you fail so badly
one time my buddy's like hey watch this
and you had a peanut M&M he threw it
like ten feet in the air open his mouth
the M&M came down hit his front two
broke his tooth in half oh my god it was
incredible I was like thank you so much
for telling me to watch that I needed
that you know you know what I love even
more than those I love when I like I'm
talking to someone and I use a big word
and I can tell that they noticed you
know you slip a big word in you can tell
they're like oh I didn't know he knew
that well you can't go too big with the
word that's a key you don't want to be
that guy that's a good way to lose
French I used to I used to work with
this guy Todd he always came in hot with
the big word I'll never forget he came
up to me one day he was like you seen
Sheila today no no a couple Sheila
he said how she just seemed really
lugubrious today the hell did you do say
you said look Magoo be is yeah nobody
knows what that means look gubrious
what's that what's that mean he said oh
sorry lugubrious means sad Sheila seemed
really sad how don't you stay sad then
that's fine right now you seem like a
real lugubrious sack of [ __ ]
now the key is you don't go too big you
go just big enough to make an impact but
not so big that it disrupts the flow of
the conversation that sweet spot you
know I was I was bowling with the buddy
and he had one of those amazing shots
you know where you like fold it and then
almost went in the gutter and then
curved at the last second came back
knocked them all down it was a strike
it's a hell of a shot and he's walking
backward me he was all pumped up and I
was like hey man that was a hell of a
shot I was worried for a second because
you were right on the precipice and yeah
it made an impact he didn't say anything
but I could see it in his eyes years ago
we moved on I got the ego boost it was a
beautiful moment but my problem is after
I use a big word I real possessive I
feel a sense of ownership if I'm talking
to you and I use a big word and I can
tell it made an impact on you I don't
want to hear that word coming out of
your mouth that's my word we both know
that it's a dark feeling but it's real I
know it's real because after I bowled my
turn I was walking back and my buddy was
talking to the two girls in the lane
beside us and they must have
complimented his shot because as I was
walking back I heard him talking to them
and he's like oh thank you so much I was
worried for a second because it was
right on the precipice
I was like hey man talk to you for a
second
he was like yeah what's up what's up so
you're you're using purpose now you
didn't even know that word five minutes
ago dude he said I did too I said he's
did not he said I did - okay stop
admonishing me
that's my bad that son min didn't
realize I was talking to a fellow
sesquipedalian over here and he said
indubitably that's a good answer
relax it's only you and me and
sesquipedalian by the way someone who
likes you using big words feel free to
use that one just not around me thank
you very much
[Applause]